along with these other television
providers giving you a front row seat to
democracy
comedian john stewart joined other
advocates to highlight veterans who are
battling disease after exposure to toxic
burn pits they testified before the
house veterans affairs committee for two
and a half hours
good afternoon everyone thank you for
joining us
for this very important roundtable
discussion
but before we proceed i'd like to go
over some items for our remote round
table to ensure that everyone can
participate in a meaningful way
first
if you are experiencing connectivity
issues please make sure you or your
staff
contact our designated technical support
so those issues can be resolved
immediately
to ensure members and participants can
have robust engagement i ask that
members participating remotely continue
to remain visible on camera for the
duration of their participation in the
round table unless they experience
connectivity issues or other technical
problems that render the number unable
to fully participate on camera
also i ask that all participants remain
muted when not speaking so that
background noise does not interfere when
someone else is speaking
regarding the format of the round table
it is my intention that the discussion
be as conversational as possible
however given the large number of parts
the large number of participants and the
need to keep things moving it will be
necessary to have some structure
accordingly it is my intent to move
through the bill title by title
with 10 to 20 minutes per section
depending on the number of member
questions
i would also ask that members and
participants raise their hands should
they have questions
and i will do my best to alternate
between members of the majority minority
and participants from the vsos
in addition i ask that members and
participants keep their questioning and
comments to a couple of minutes so that
we can cover as much ground as possible
the z member have a question about the
procedures for this roundtable
hearing none and seeing none will
proceed
well today i'm thrilled to welcome our
esteemed veterans advocates and veteran
service organizations to this virtual
roundtable to discuss two critically
important matters
to our veterans and their families
in-service toxic exposures
and the honoring our pact act
when we set our service members into
harm's way we made a pact to care for
them
and pay for that care
when they came home
for too long
congress and the department of veterans
affairs have been slow to act
citing high costs or lack of absolute
scientific proof
the result
a disability benefit claims process that
is cumbersome and places the burden to
prove
toxic exposure on veterans themselves
every day more and more veterans speak
out about
exposure to environmental hazards and
other toxic substances during their
military service
recently i put out a call encouraging
toxic exposed veterans to share their
experiences with the committee
as of this morning the committee has
heard from over 400 veterans in 48
states
these reflections are very powerful and
i'd like to share some with you now
navy veteran ed b described how toxic
exposures could overwhelm the census
he wrote quote
you couldn't escape
in brackets the jet fuel
you could see it smell it and taste it
end quote
i heard from marine veteran mike m who
said
quote even when we weren't actively
engaged in dumping items into the burn
pit
we were still exposed and quote
air force veteran christopher r
described his dealings with va stating
quote
i continue to be rejected because they
say it's impossible to prove
that it is service related i never
worked with chemicals before my service
or since
i feel like a nuisance to the va health
system unquote
i heard from the widow of army veteran
austin monk who said quote
no wife should have to bury her 22 year
old husband because of his exposure to
unsafe conditions while in service to
his country end quote
listening to their stories
it is incredibly clear to me
that we need to pass the honoring our
packed act now
the speaker has committed to bringing
this bill to the floor very soon
so
we need to be prepared to bring the best
possible version of this bill to the
floor
this bill has gone through the full
legislative process including a full
committee legislative hearing and markup
this is now the time to bring together
stakeholders and committee members to
discuss the path forward
where there is common ground
and where we need to get down the brass
tax to get this bill ready for the floor
our bipartisan bill will address the
full gamut of issues affecting toxic
exposed veterans access to high
access to va care and benefits while
reforming va's presumptive
decision-making process
it will open up va healthcare for more
than 3.5 million veterans exposed to
burn fits and establish a presumption of
service connection for over 23
respiratory illnesses and cancers
it's time congress and the american
people back up
thank you for your service
with action
toxic exposed veterans have held up
their part of the pact
now
it's our turn
the cbo estimate for the honorary pact
act is in
now we know the true cost of our promise
but we cannot renege on our
responsibility to toxic exposed veterans
because of any preconceived sticker
shock
over the past 20 years congress and our
country have made the choice to spend
trillions
on other priorities while sending
service members into harm's way at a
cost of
6.4 trillion dollars
we know that this congress is willing to
find money when it wants to
as it recently demonstrated by adding 25
billion dollars to the last national
defense authorization
so
the question is
how can we improve this bill to ensure
the fullest support
and its passage
i'm eager to hear what my colleagues
across the aisle would like to change
that would still uphold this sacred
promise
when our country goes to war we don't
nickel and dime the department of
defense
and we shouldn't try to pinch pennies
when it comes to covering the care of
the care
for toxic exposed veterans
it's time to pass the autoimpact act
and i'm grateful to have all of you here
for our discussion
today ranking member boss
i would like to give you the opportunity
to add any opening remarks before we
introduce our guests and thank you mr
chairman andy i want to thank everyone
here for joining us today i'm grateful
to each one of you for your commitment
to our veterans the veterans uh you or
your organized your organizations
represent
uh understand the challenges posed by
toxic exposure all too well
you know during our markup last june we
discussed those challenges with respect
to chairman takano's packed act
the committee was painfully under under
prepared to vote on the bill at that
point
we were working off a minimal cost
information from cbo and a race radio
silence from the biden administration
we now have some of the information and
that and it's clear that we have more to
do more work to do and i appreciate the
round table as a first step
but given the focus on the pac act we
will not be able to discuss everything
we need to today for example
we would likely won't have the
opportunity to discuss the new work that
the va is doing to better support toxic
exposed veterans at this time va
recently recent actions should
inform our work on this issue not repeat
or compete with it
and as i have said before we need to
work as partners
on a parallel path with each other and
the senate to get this done
we have not done that thus far
and our work to support toxic exposure
exposed veterans has suffered for it
i understand the senate is currently
exposed exploring a phase
phased approach to address toxic
exposure that would prioritize care for
those who need it now i think that's
wise
those of us who attended last year's
legislative hearing may remember
jim price's testimony
jim combat veteran whose wife lauren
tragically passed away from conditions
likely linked to toxic exposure
i know many of you work with lauren and
miss her dearly
to quote jim's testimony
benefits are
great
but they mean nothing to somebody that
is dead because they didn't get care
end quote
jim put it perfectly
we need to focus on taking action steps
now to expand care to those who need it
most before it's too late
additionally we still need to identify a
way to pay for toxic exposure
legislation
cbo estimates that that the pac act
would cost roughly 280 billion in a new
mandatory spending and 147 billion in
new discretionary spending
we don't have hundreds of billion
dollars in offsets laying around last
week i opposed the veterans bill on the
floor in part because i believe we
needed to preserve offsets for toxic
exposure and make that focus be there
i remain committed to finding a way to
support toxic exposed veterans in a way
that is fiscally responsible for a
future generations
i believe we can do that
speaking as a veteran myself
i don't think that's too much to ask
veterans are taxpayers too
we should be mindful of how we spend
their money
on their behalf
i look forward to seeing
where each of you organizations might be
on
uh or
might be on all of these items and to be
honest and robust discussion that we
need to have uh this afternoon about the
way moving forward
uh thank you mr chairman for having this
round table and i look forward to uh the
discussion here today and with that i
yield back
thank you ranking member boss i will now
introduce our participants from the
veterans advocacy and vso communities
joining us this afternoon is mr john
stewart veteran's advocate
mr john field veterans advocate
ms rosie lopez torres
executive director burn pitts 360.
mr patrick murray director of national
legislative service veterans
of foreign wars of the united states of
america
mr shane lehrman
deputy national legislative director of
disabled american veterans
mr ronald brown toxic wounds consultant
vietnam veterans of america
lindsay church executive director
minority veterans of america
mr alex
marowski
uh deputy director of government affairs
wounded warrior project
ms jan burch
government relations and communications
associate iraq and afghanistan veterans
of america
mr advaith tampi
tampi
legislative associate the american
legion
mr corey titus director of veterans
benefits and a guard reserve affairs
military officers the military
association military officers
association of america moa
mr roscoe butler associate legislative
director paralyzed veterans of america
and mr jim vale
national service director of veterans
benefits and policy blinded veterans
association
the interest of time to keep things
moving i'd like to begin our discussion
and turn to title one
of the
uh bill
expansion of health care eligibility for
toxic exposed veterans
uh mr marowski
can you share wounded warriors project
with the wounded warrior project's
perspective on the language of that
section
uh you're miss marshall your
sound is still
can you hear me i can hear you now go
ahead proceed okay thank you mr chairman
and good afternoon uh chairman takano
ranking member boss and members of the
committee i'm alex morrowski from
wounded warrior project i want to thank
you for holding this round table
and for inviting us to participate in
this discussion on the honoring our pact
act it's bill we strongly support
um i want to start off by acknowledging
that there were many toxic exposure
bills introduced this congress
and what you've done with the pact act
is you've put them together to create a
comprehensive solution for veterans who
are exposed
and while there are many necessary
provisions in this bill that i know that
we'll be discussing today which include
presumption concession of exposure
scientific framework i have to take a
couple minutes to talk about title one
which would finally expand permanent va
healthcare and roman eligibility to all
veterans who were exposed during their
military service regardless of their
disability claim status
we believe this is absolutely critical
not only for veterans who are already
suffering from exposure-related
illnesses but from a preventative care
standpoint as well
and i would like to point out that
vietnam veterans have permanent
guaranteed access to va health care due
to exposure to agent orange current era
veterans who are exposed need the same
access for the same reasons
and if i could i'd like to illustrate
this point by briefly telling you a
story about a warrior named scott evans
scott was a marine he deployed twice to
afghanistan as a combat engineer and as
a dog handler where he was exposed to
burn pits
he says that they were even encouraged
to spend time near the burn pits with
the dogs to see if they could still
sniff the munitions among the burning
waste so in other words
the burn pits were used as a training
area in his case
eventually he was honorably discharged
in 2012.
he got a job he never felt the need to
enroll in va medical care
or
put in a disability claim because he
felt that he suffered no significant
disabilities
it wasn't until eight years later in the
spring of 2020 that he started
experiencing severe abdominal pain
and losing weight rapidly and at that
point he knew something was wrong tried
to enroll at his local va but he learned
that he was not eligible since he never
filed a claim
and he was beyond the five-year enhanced
eligibility period for combat veterans
over the course of next several months
scott accumulated about twenty thousand
dollars in medical bills seeking
diagnosis and treatment for his
condition
and it wasn't until later that year that
a friend that he served with connected
into wounded warrior project we were
able to get him service connected
not for his toxic exposure illness but
for other things and enrolled at the ba
but his diagnosis at that point several
months later was terminal pancreatic
cancer
um
scott says that he's received good care
since he's been enrolled but
understandably he can't help but wonder
if his cancer would have been would have
been operable
if it was caught months sooner when he
initially tried to enroll
mr chairman we believe no veteran who
served in an area of known exposure
should ever be turned away from the va
unfortunately scott's not alone we
estimate there are as many as 750 000
iraq and afghanistan veterans who are
currently ineligible for va healthcare
enrollment due to the fact that they've
been unable to establish a
service-connected disability within five
years of discharge so that's 750 000
veterans who served in areas of known
exposure who are now operating without a
safety net should they become ill and we
don't think any of them should ever be
turned away like scott was and so for
this reason we strongly believe that
guaranteed access to care for all
exposed veterans in title one of the
honoring our pact act is absolutely
critical and has to be part of any
comprehensive toxic exposure solution
this congress
so once again i'd like to thank you mr
chairman and i'd like to turn it back
over to you at this point
well thank you uh for that testimony mr
morosk it was
very heart-wrenching to hear that that
story uh
i will now uh
yeah i'll ask the first question under
title one
um
in title one uh
it's updating the definition of toxic
exposure risk activity
actual language
in the bill to mean any activity with an
entry in
the individual longitudinal exposure
record or eiler iler
or other exposure records such as the
defense occupational and environmental
health right in the system
uh a revision
uh everyone here could support so is
is basically the definition something
that uh
that
you all that everybody here
minority members majority members
vso community advocates
can we live with this toxic exposure
activity risk activity definition
to mean any activity with an entry in
the idler or the defense occupational
and environmental health right in the
system
is this a revision that we can support
are there concerns
is there anybody who
can't support it that might be the
easier question easier way to respond is
there anybody who
can't support this
revised definition
all right
uh i will take that as that
yes
go ahead alex go ahead
thank you mr chairman um does this uh
revised definition also include the uh
dates and locations that are listed in i
believe it's section 302
this revised definition i'm seeing my
staff shake their heads no
does not include the dates
that's something we should take note of
well we'll take that under discussion
and so we don't have to get bogged down
with that i want to keep things moving
uh mr vale
do you have a comment mr vale on on uh
title one
uh thank you mr chairman um i just have
a uh concern about
first off i want to say bva supports
this legislation
um
but we also want to point out you know
it's
it's not good policy to over promise and
deliver if this is not
done
correctly we could run the risk of
repeating the sins of the past
a lot of good
people lot of good people work at ba and
their hands are often
tied due to resource limitations
good legislative intent sometimes ends
up with rulemaking that results in
unintended consequences
vha is operating at full capacity right
now that's our understanding
when considering the influx of new
eligible veterans if this legislation
will will provide for it
um it would only seem natural that this
is too great of a burden for vha to bear
unto itself
consequently this will fall on the
community care networks to deliver
these new newly eligible veterans
healthcare
is this too great a burden for the
community care networks to bear
has the
full cost to fund this additional
demand for health care uh been
considered
this is happening right now with the
defense health agency dependents on
tricare are being sent out from the
military treatment facilities to the
community real and remote providers are
overloaded and cannot absorb more
patients
how can they handle more patients such
as these new veterans who are eligible
under this legislation
are we unintentionally creating a
perfect storm
you know giving somebody a benefit they
can't access
um that's
that's really frustrating
and so i ask
are we creating an underfunded mandate
here we support the legislation but
we're concerned about about having
adequate funding to support it thank you
well thank you mr bill we definitely
have noted your concerns and i think
they're valid ones
but let me go on to uh ranking member
boss
thank you mr chairman
this is a question that i want to ask
all of our vsos and everybody that's
involved uh with title 1 here would you
agree that addressing eligibility for
health care should be our first priority
and if everybody agrees and i'll but if
you don't agree let me know that
okay because that's going to lead to my
second question and and then is would
you support a proposal that extends
eligibility for care without expanding
benefits while we continue to work on
how to best proceed so in other words
we're getting it the the the to the
opening statement that i made which is
there's people that need the care now so
let's move forward with that provide
that at a level that we can and then
continue to work for the longer goal for
this bill
anybody disagree with that
frankie remember both i just have a
comment on that rosie torres from burn
pits 360. i think my concern with that
is
how well equipped is the va to handle
those complex patients coming in with
you know these underlying diseases that
up until now they're passing off as
psychosomatic issues
they're diagnosing people with mental
health issues as opposed to these
underlying cancers that are killing
veterans
and i'll give you an example
uh sergeant wesley black who was on
um jon stewart's show recently uh you
know he died and he was misdiagnosed so
my biggest concern would be
what
what what training would be facilitated
to these clinicians
are they trained in occupational
medicine are they trained in
epidemiology there's so much that it
takes
to properly assess these kinds of health
issues
that would be my only concern um is is
is i don't want
to see what is happening now continue to
happen
that's it so respectfully so that that's
probably one of the reasons why it's so
vitally important to get the input from
the va
so we know where they are what they can
handle and but also as i
said in the opening statement uh that
was so uh
so broad about in our last hearing
but while we're doing this we're doing
nothing
and that's not a good place to be
i mean we can continue we can chew gum
and walk okay we can do this
and provide for those that have and can
be diagnosed
and still continue to work on the
legislation rather than
you understand what i'm saying that's
the concern i have well thank you
thank you i understand this i have i mr
brown
uh ron brown i
understand you have a response
yes uh
yeah i'm sorry representative boss uh
question i have uh would be
what about the people who have the
terminal cancers
and uh they're unable to work
how would the compensation
i mean where would it come from
that's what i'm saying we can continue
to work to try to get that done as quick
as possible too but the the but the
situation is we do know those that are
exposed we do know those that need the
medical treatment that they can receive
right now we can move forward with
getting that part out
and be taken care of and then continue
we do that with legislation every day
we that's how we create legislation
quite often is we move forward knowing
that we can definitely positively do
this and then let's keep working to try
to get it better and better and better
but right now we're not doing anything
okay in respects to the isler system
is that going to go back to cover
the earlier veterans before 9 11 with
the known exposures that the va has on
their website already or is that just
solely for
the post 9 11 veterans
uh
mr brown my understanding is is that the
uh
the tyler would would
address the post 9 11 veterans
not pre-9 11 veterans
so um either is a system that's still
it's it's actually been created now it's
it's something that's being done now
it's i don't think we have we don't
think we have data for pre-911
vets
so
okay chairman i understand what you're
saying the uh
the va already has the known exposures
listed on the office of public health
for the previous deployments before 9
11. and that's what i was wondering if
those would be added into the isler
system
they are planning
that is um
that is that is in the that is also sort
of being contemplated now to answer your
question is
uh that is the intention i do want to
move on keep this movement uh to uh
uh next uh who put up her hand was uh ms
flocken
go ahead and slack on title one
um i appreciate everyone being here
today and i think everybody
wants to do the right thing and make
sure that the burn pits of the
particularly the post-9 11 generation
isn't you know doesn't live through the
same experience that our vietnam vets
who were exposed to agent orange went
through where it was years and years and
studies and just demands on their time
to make their case in the va while
people died from exposure we're trying
to avoid repeating recent history um and
i appreciate everyone um being here you
know i have a part of the the bill that
we're considering peter meyer
representative peter meyer and i did the
um burn pit exposure act just to make it
easier and to have some presumption when
you walk in um and i know you know
obviously it costs money to treat people
who have been exposed to these things i
think we all know know deep down that
it's part of our responsibility and i
would just note for my colleagues on the
other side of the aisle who are so
worried about the money all but one of
you voted for the 25 billion dollar
increase to the defense budget so it
just to be consistent here if you're
gonna be deeply deeply concerned about
the spending of money i would expect the
same scrutiny to a bill you passed and
voted on
in december that we are now giving to
helping our veterans um i would just ask
rosie if you could um just from your
experience
you know i think it's sometimes hard
when you do policy to just you sort of
lose your ability to understand what
this means for human beings
and i know your experience through your
husband was really powerful when i heard
it
talk about his experience of trying to
make his case and what it means so that
this committee understands what our
veterans are going through every day
just to get that recognition
oh i mean look it and thank you so much
to all of you for this opportunity um
it was it's is years and years i mean i
worked at the va for 23 years so i sort
of understood you know the red tape we
were we were we were about to face
um but it was just years and years of
delay
on both the department of defense side
and the department of veterans affairs
site so we we we basically went to every
healthcare facility within the two
systems
i mean to prove a point and then most
importantly to try and get answers right
i already knew
the outcome was going to be even
traveling over the war-related illness
and injury center
and in between that we had
non-profit organizations you know
filling the gap financially because we
had already exhausted our life savings
in my husband's case
it was more
of us being forced to find an answer
because his employer
was getting ready to let him go right he
was a state police in the state of texas
and then they forced him to resign after
we finally were able to
receive a solid diagnosis from dr robert
miller over at vanderbilt university
prior to that every answer was just
basically a diagnosis of unknown
ideology
anxiety
you know it was very frustrating so we
knew um that that we weren't the only
family experiencing this hardship
and so after you exhaust all your life
savings and trying to access care
which we're still sort of there he was
recently hospitalized for the same
issues as the gentleman that alex
morrowski talked about we don't know if
he's got pancreatic cancer it's a huge
possibility um but you know the
challenges that these families face
aside from trying to access care
is you hear story after story of these
survivors widows
uh spending their last
days with their loved one trying to
collect buddy statements
from their loved ones uh you know
brothers and sisters during wartime just
to try and figure out how will i put
food on the table for my children once
my loved one is gone
um and and we know that's being done on
a case-by-case basis but that's not
enough
i mean it's it it's very scary
to to to even think about you know going
to the va
um because
even their own staff tells us if you
have tricare go on the outside it'll
take forever
and now this is their own staff telling
in making these kinds of advice and
encouragement so i mean while i know the
va is working on things the reality is
that in in this community of people
impacted
you know there's neither the presumption
nor the health care happening you know
um i know veterans that have walked into
appointments and
they leave
hopeless you know i don't know how many
people have
put a bullet in their head
because they're so hopeless at the end
of the day they're losing their homes
they're losing their vehicles they're
losing their jobs
so much so that and i'll end with this
you know
the injustice behind all of this
continues on to like where we are as my
family today
leroy's uh job loss
is will now be heard before the united
states supreme court
because it's not okay to treat the
veterans the way they're being treated
so you know i just encourage everyone to
understand it from every perspective
that you know not only as a family but
as an organization we've collected data
there are people in everyone's districts
coming forward and saying the same thing
so thank you congressman
thank you rosie thank you rosie uh mr
stewart um
i understand you have something to say
yeah thanks so much i i just wanted to
zoom out for a second you know as we're
all talking about you know different
funding and different bureaucratic fixes
to just get a a larger perspective on on
what the reality of this
should probably be
you know the va is instituting another
bureaucratic process to decide if there
are certain conditions which might meet
the protocol and criterion that they're
working to establish to make sure
that a veteran in what is generally seen
by the community as an adversarial
process
can tie the toxic exposure that he
experienced in iraq and afghanistan
to the conditions uh that they're
suffering now and we want to talk about
do we have enough money there really
should be one job here in one job alone
and that is how
do we implement
first-rate toxic exposure health care
for our iraq and afghanistan veterans so
that they can receive in the way that
the va and dod have gotten better with
traumatic brain injury and pts
man if you went down to walter reed in
2004
you'd have the adaptive rehabilitation
there was two double amputees lying on a
mat throwing a medicine ball back and
forth and if you go there now it is
world class they have the world-class
corrective surgeries they have
world-class prosthetics
they have world-class
technology and adaptive rehabilitation
but it took intention and it took money
and we have to establish that for the
veterans of iraq and afghanistan because
a toxic wound is an ied that goes off in
your body five years later 10 years
later 15 years later and yet the burden
of proof and scrutiny is always on the
veteran and so respectfully when we talk
about hey we just want to get him into
health care now
access to a system that doesn't
understand toxic exposure
doesn't help anybody
there's a burn pit center for excellence
at the va
its funding is six to seven million
dollars a year that's in 2022 15 years
after the dod and the va
knew that this storm was coming
to give you just a a a perspective on
that they spend 90 million dollars a
year on viagra
if a budget is uh a list of your
priorities i think that shows where
everything stands so when i hear
everybody say well we've got to get it
right here's the problem with the va
they're afraid of being overwhelmed
the only conversation we should be
having is a collaborative effort
to bring the va together and create
first-rate toxic exposure health care
and not health care first and benefits
later because if you're
sick with pancreatic cancer not having
your benefit what are you living on
so the idea that we need to split
everything up and do it piecemeal and
create more bureaucratic processes of
this is unacceptable the bottom line is
this
our country exposed our own veterans to
poison for years and we knew about it
and we didn't act with urgency and
appropriateness
and therefore we've lost
men and women who served this country
they've died
out of our inaction
and so i just want to step back for a
second and don't worry so much about the
protocol for a new disease and things
like that let's not lose the big picture
because i know everybody here wants to
do the right thing and it's really
appreciated
i just don't want to get lost in the
sauce here
thanks
thank you thank you uh john
uh
i have uh in the queue the following
members uh
uh miller meeks luria
levin and tron we are now out of time
for title one but i'm gonna take one
more i'll take uh ms miller meeks's
question for
uh title one i will keep uh miss luria
mr levin mr trone in the queue for uh
the discussion on title two you can go
back to title one but we gotta keep this
moving so uh mrs miller meeks
you have your opportunity to make a
comment on title one or whatever
uh thank you chair takano and uh thank
you income member boston to all of our
panelists are presenting so this
question comes from uh being a 24 year
military veteran and family members who
are veterans an uncle who spent his
entire life
uh in a va facility after his ship went
down pacific in world war ii
um and and also as a physician and i
have a
friend who um developed cardiomyopathy
after desert storm which impacted both
the life of he and his wife and and us
of of course as his friends and so my
concern is this there is a tremendous
health care shortage it's not only at
the va hospital i know one of the bills
we may be voting on will be on trying to
alleviate some of that but all across
this country i represent a rural
district there are health care shortages
there are personnel shortages there are
specialist shortages and so i think it's
a valid uh
point to bring up that
um and i think mr vale mentioned this
that saying that someone has a benefit
doesn't get them health care it only
gets them a benefit so
you know is there a possibility and
could we envision a phased-in um
approach to healthcare access
for toxic exposed veterans as we
continue to determine the science
on whether or not a toxic exposure is
truly related to an organic health care
problem or disease
that's it i'm respecting my time okay
well thank you if there's no response
we'll move on to title two
uh
uh thank you ms miller meeks uh i uh
uh for title two
uh
the discussion um
let me just go to my question here for
title two
oh yeah yes mr murray that's the process
mr murray you're now recognized to begin
our discussion on title two toxic
exposure presumption process mr murray
you're recognized uh for your remarks
uh good afternoon everyone thank you uh
chairman takano
rank member boss for getting everyone
together um thank you for the
opportunity to speak on this important
subject uh comprehensive tax exposure
reform is the vfw's number one
legislative goal for the 117th congress
uh we're confident that with this many
people all pulling in the same direction
we can
finally accomplish that goal one of the
most common issues we've heard from
countless vfw members is the difficulty
getting care and benefits for illnesses
uh believed to be due to tax exposure um
military service is synonymous with
toxic exposure
decades decades since world war one
world war ii korea vietnam desert storm
iraq afghanistan and other places around
the world is synonymous with service but
unfortunately the burden of proof has
been put too heavily on the individual
veterans for decades and it's far past
time to revamp that process
a major step in it in the process is
updating how presumptives are granted
and
va is currently undergoing a pilot
program which
hopefully will
improve the process and make it
considerably easier for veterans to be
granted toxic exposure presumptives
we're encouraged
by the willingness of secretary
mcdonough to update revise the process
we're hopeful that the end result will
be something we're all in favor of
however
the vfw does have some serious concerns
about some of the specific details
of that pilot program
we've been engaged by va
and we have to keep those lines of
communications open in order to achieve
success
but that's the whole point of a pilot
program is to hammer out what works what
doesn't and hopefully produce a great
product that works for veterans
the next important step is in revising
the presumptive process is codifying
what works
the vfw is supportive of many of the
pieces of legislation that strive to set
in place a new framework for toxic
exposure presumptives there are parts to
different bills that we think would get
the job done right
the team act for example proposes an
independent commission that is outside
of va
even if we have full faith and
confidence in the current situation at
va to do all the right thing we've seen
time and time again
va secretaries failed to solve this
problem due to varying issues
the vfw believes there should be an
element of an independent body in the
overall process
in the pact act it calls for internal va
commissions we believe there is a
critical role for that but not only to
have internal va commissions or boards
we believe a combination of both is the
best path forward
additionally the pact act proposes a
specific timeline
for officially accepting or declining
the recommendations of the varying
boards
this is critical because far too long
studies and reports have waited on
decisions for years all the while
veterans were getting sick and dying
we're hopeful to continue this process
today and every day for the remainder of
the 117th congress
we may have differing opinions about how
the end product should look regarding
tax exposure presumptives but the one
thing i believe we can all agree on is
the current process is broken
and it's not helping veterans to the
fullest extent
and we need to do something to fix it
i'm glad we're all here today to make
that happen thank you very much for the
time oh well thank you uh
i i well thank you uh mr uh
nirman for the uh
mr murray mr murray for your comment uh
on title two
uh i'll go to my question
uh va
va suggests that our proposed approach
to the toxic exposure presumption
process outlined in section 202
uh that would add more complexity to the
process and further delay
answers that veterans are currently
seeking on toxic exposures
they request that we strike this new
framework
however at the same time va is actively
developing their own new framework for
presumptions
there is nothing in place to prevent
this secretary or the next secretary
from changing or eliminating it
by putting the requirements in law
we ensure the framework remains in place
for future generations of toxic exposed
veterans
does everyone agree on this point
if not why not i invite
feedback at this point on
title 2 and this question of putting
a framework into law mr chairman the
uh frank of the assertion that this
would delay it any further
is flat out wrong i don't know how you
delay never getting something done toxic
exposure is not getting done in any way
shape or form in any kind of speedy
fashion so this is not going to delay it
um you can't delay something this isn't
being done uh this would put it
in law hopefully again this we have uh
differing feelings about exactly
specifics va's presumptive pilot process
is different than what we're talking
about today um i think what va did in
rolling out a pilot without bringing in
everybody ahead of time
simply producing here's what we're doing
um we hope everybody gives it a thumbs
up that's not the best way to do it we
would prefer to get brought in in order
to form that so we don't waste time and
then going back for a version two or
version three so on and so forth um no i
do not think uh that it would delay it
it's necessary we've got to do something
to make it
speedy um secretary mcdonough said that
there's a perceived
level of denial with tax exposure that's
not perceived that's a reality
right now they're denying about 80
um
we got to get that
we got to get that entirely flipped
around so uh whatever efforts we can do
to actually get something on the books
that works that's what needs to happen
well thank you mr murray um mr ross get
a quick response
uh yes mr chairman we appreciate the
fact that um the va is doing its own
pilot program to have a framework we
agree that a framework is going to be
necessary in any event but it's also
going to have to be codified in any
event
[Music]
go ahead mr butler
roscoe butler i think you had your
he's not saying anything
something in regard to title one
uh you can go ahead and say something
without a one that's fine uh i i was
just gonna say that um i agree that it's
important that we we don't uh
put benefits and health care at odds
with one another but we but something
needs to be done immediately because
veterans are
not getting the benefits that they
deserve it shouldn't be
uh whether we have the resources to
provide the care of services it should
be
what is the right way to provide the
benefits that they deserve today and
move forward in ensuring that
uh i'd like to provision in title one
that
provides for
a report on whether uh va has the
resources
and um and necessary to meet the needs
of the section and if not to provide a
report to congress on what that is that
allows the framework for va to get the
resources uh the adequate resource
needed to provide a full continuum of
benefits healthcare benefits to veterans
but we shouldn't uh delay it
to uh put the one benefit at odds with
the other
thank you thank you mr mr butler uh we
do need to move on to ranking member
boss and mr rankinger boss go ahead
thank you and and as we're trying to
work through this i just need to know
you know
what the vsos believe what what's the
scientific standard
that congress should put in place
for va to establish the new uh
presumptions of exposure and then a
second question i have too and anybody
can answer either one of these but do
you believe the va pilot program uh
that the va pilot program
will establish uh the presumptions of
exposure will increase transparency
transparency
and improve the process with with what
we're doing right now with the pilot
program
regular boss the scientific standard the
vfw believes be positive association uh
not causation um that was one of the uh
initial sticking points in the first
draft i guess of the pilot program va
has gone back and revised that we're
we're grateful that they're listening
um more transparency we certainly hope
so um
as we we saw on uh
mr stewart's show
it was very difficult to explain
a a presumptive process there were a
couple smart individuals in that room
and it really sounded like it was very
difficult so how do we
explain it to our members who who don't
do this every single day they feel like
they're going like they're going against
an adversarial um process so that's the
biggest thing we we hope is transparent
we hope it's easy to understand and we
hope it gets veterans the care and
benefits they need
red bull
miss burch
ms burch go ahead and then i'll call him
mr brown
uh yes um i agree with everyone that
they've what they've said so far but uh
the big thing is that we need to remove
the burden of proof from the veteran and
remember that because
me personally it took me seven years to
get my disability approved for toxic
exposure
it took over six er trips and thousands
of dollars later
that i'll never get that money back but
thankfully i have medical care and in
that seven years
that nodule that was in my lung doubled
in size and now every year i have to go
get screened to make sure it doesn't
turn into cancer and i think we need to
keep the veteran in the forefront of
this conversation and that right now
we have veterans that are dying we have
veterans that are just finding out that
they have health impacts from toxic
exposure and we have future veterans
that don't even know what's to come in
their future
and so i think the presumptions here is
that we need to
make sure we look at the vietnam
veterans and what their presumptions are
because there's a lot of similarities
there what the gulf war veterans have
been experiencing and bring in a panel
of maybe non-va doctors for example you
have the national jewish health in
denver colorado with some of the top
pulmonologists in the world and you
bring them in you sit down and you take
a look at some of these cases and decide
what are these top presumptions that are
going to be and so that we can start
removing that burden of proof so for
example myself and other veterans i had
to be my own lawyer my own medical
advisor my own advocate put everything
together in the most organized way to
submit it to the va in hopes that they
would approve it and thankfully i was
part of that 20 percent but 80 of us are
still not getting those benefits and in
the meantime there are veterans that are
dying like sergeant wesley black
all right thank you very much real
quickly mr brown yes uh rep boss i can
show you approximately 20 to 30 years
worth of national academy reports on
gulf war and health
that they have
illnesses like acute leukemia and a
plastic anemia in its highest category
of of a casual or association the va has
never added any of these
and they're the ones who contracted
through the national academy of medicine
to do the studies and there's hundreds
of conditions like that in those volumes
but none of those have ever been added
as a presumptive under the va
all right well thank you i i do want to
do
ms mr levin mr levin go ahead
thank you uh thank you mr chairman for
convening this roundtable and and thanks
to our bso leaders thanks to our other
guests
my question is for both pat murray and
for jon stewart
and uh it seems obvious that everybody
here
wants to do the right thing
but only some want to pay
uh for what is the right thing and and
so my question is what message does it
send
to our service members and to our
veterans
if we dismiss the comprehensive reform
that we need
due to the cost due to the cost of doing
what is so obviously
the right thing
and what do you think this says about
our values as a nation
[Music]
uh mr levin i think the the pay for
for all this was our plane tickets to
overseas um
that's what paid for
uh this this care and benefits uh
there's far too many people that
raised the right hand to go do whatever
it was and there was no consideration at
the time uh for you know how we're gonna
you know what taxes are going to be used
for this
10 years from now 20 years from now
unfortunately you know from from many of
mr brown's folks in that area that was
50 years later 60 years later so that
kind of stuff's completely unacceptable
the cost of war is exactly what this is
it's just a continuation this is phase
two of it uh this is this is the next
step this is critical
uh so to put together with the total
cost of being in the military
mr lehrman do you have a response
or comment
oh no
mr chairman i was actually interested in
mr stewart's thoughts on this as well
okay
you know
i would say simply this it's we are a
country that loves its veterans or
certainly we we purport to
and we support the troops
and we put on our flag pins
and we stand
and they get discounts at denny's
but the true support
of having a veteran's back is is when
they need the support
and when they are sick and dying
due to
the service that they gave to this
country and they come back and are put
under scrutiny and are made to be
defendants
in a case concerning their own health
care and lives
it's unacceptable and it's the lowest
hanging fruit
of a functioning society
and so much of this is just pure common
sense and if we could just stand back
for a moment outside of the bureaucratic
impact of all this
and and stop thinking about the process
by which i would challenge every
congressional leader in this uh room
today or on this call
go back to your district
and dig a 10 acre pit
and put everything that that town
discards into that pit
and burn it with jet fuel and diesel
fuel and put in hazardous materials for
god's sakes the burning the smoking gun
in this case is literally smoking guns
and then
burn that pit 24 hours a day seven days
a week
but tell your constituents don't worry
15 years from now
we're going to convene a panel
to discuss whether or not the health
issues that you're having are in your
head
or not and we're going to make you get a
lawyer to prove it
look
we've got all these diseases lined up
ground zero in manhattan is a burn pit
was a burn pit
the men and women who sat on that pile
and dug through it
suffered the very same illnesses and
diseases that we are seeing now
we've created a program for john field
and this droga act with the uh not it's
it's administered by niosh in the
department of justice it is effective it
is targeted it
deals with prevention and screening
and healthcare these programs exist
you don't need to reinvent the wheel
and we shouldn't have blinders on to
this idea that this process and these
diseases we've not been allowed to use
burn pits in the united states since the
1970s
the epa has already gone through the
list
of cancers and immune issues and and
pulmonary issues and lung issues
why are we relitigating this
when thousands and thousands of veterans
their very lives depend on the urgency
of your actions
so that's my thought
uh thank you mr stewart thank you mr
levin uh we do need to move on and we
have i'm going to ask mr lehrman to
be the last uh comment on the title ii
section so mr aluminum go ahead
uh thank you
appreciate the opportunity today i think
the big thing to point out in reference
to some of the conversations about
presumptions and
codifying it and waiting for va vasa
takes too long there are many examples
we can look at agent orange and vietnam
veterans in 2016 there were several
diseases associated with that exposure
however it took you
an act of congress to get them passed
because va didn't get it done
so any process that we go forward must
be transparent va must include the vsos
and it should be codified so we're
protected from secretaries or
administrations that aren't going to
take that action in the future
all right well thank you thank you that
for mr lerman um i will now move on to
uh title three and uh mr trump mr geiger
you're in the queue as members
um
so i thank um
uh
you all for the discussion on title two
mr lehrman you're now going to
lead our discussion on title 3
which is about improving the
establishment of service connection for
toxic exposed veterans so go ahead and
read your
go and present your comments for title
three
thank you chairman appreciate it title
three establishes a presumption of
exposure
also known as a concession of exposure
what does this mean this means that va
will concede exposures
as identified in idlers and those
determined
by the va secretary to include
roughly 50 different toxins
in 17 countries as related to burn pit
exposure
these are were already identified
in air sampling reports by the united
states army and also va currently
recognizes those toxins as well so by
establishing this concession of exposure
what are we doing we're removing the
veterans
we're removing their burden of proof
they don't have to prove what they were
exposed to this concession of exposure
will concede if they were there here's
what they were exposed to right now 78
of claims for direct service connection
on conditions related to burn pits are
being denied
this can help change that by conceding
yes they were exposed and
let's take it a step further it will
also require va to provide a medical
opinion and an examination if there is
not sufficient evidence for them to
grant that on a direct service
connection
why is this so important well let's say
we don't have presumptive diseases yet
this removes those obstacles for
veterans to get direct service
connection now let's say we do have
presumptive diseases but this veteran
has one not on the list
this will help them get direct service
connection so this is a huge part of the
bill dav fully supports this because
you're giving veterans a fighting chance
whether there's a presumptive disease a
presumptive list and more importantly
it's removing those obstacles to get
what they need to get service connection
and they don't have to prove
their exposure now real quick i just
want to comment on a few of the other
things we've talked about one i i am
disappointed to hear
that the healthcare entitled one uh the
proposal would exclude
the veterans listed under title iii
which would be veterans exposed to burn
pits from the first persian gulf
and from post 9 11 toward now
these are veterans in in many rights no
longer have that five year access they
no longer have health care so i think
that amendment
really misses the mark and if we're only
going to rely on idlers ours only goes
back so many years this is not going to
catch everybody even the entire post-911
generation so i think we shouldn't
put all our eggs in that basket and then
one one last final comment on
how do we pay for all this pay go cut go
why do veterans
have to pay
for their own benefits
why do we have to cut programs inside
the veterans affairs
from one group of veterans to pay for
these groups of veterans now just to get
health care to get service connection to
get benefits we don't have to
we choose to it's a self-imposed rule we
could waive that we could find ways
to do this and dav really believes paygo
cutco should not apply
to veterans benefits
thank you very much for the opportunity
chairman's condo and ranking member boss
greatly appreciate it
thank you mr lehrman um i'm going to
go straight into uh
my question for
title three
when it comes to improving the
establishment of service connection
process for toxic exposed veterans va
states that the use of eiler is
premature since it is not an
authoritative source of exposure
information in the moment
um
but
is this a valid reason to not codify the
use of either at this time
wouldn't we want the intent of its use
firmly established for when the platform
is fully operational
uh so if there's any feedback from our
vsos or members
uh to the questions i just asked please
yes chairman
just just mr lemmer go ahead
just to address that real quick i think
iowa has potential right there is great
potential in iowa's going forward but
again it's not complete and if we codify
it too soon i'm just saying potentially
va may
then say well your exposure wasn't in
iowa so you weren't exposed you're
denied your benefits we want to make
sure we don't get to that point
now codifying it now
for the future there's nothing wrong
with that we just don't want to go down
the path of if it's not in eyewear it
didn't happen because we all know
there are 40 50 60 years worth of toxic
exposures that nobody's ever gonna know
they're not in any military records
they'll never show up in eiler so we
don't want to limit veterans by solely
relying on idlers
i hear you all right um why don't we go
to ranking member boss frank remember
boss
thank you just real quick so so anybody
want input on can give input here what's
the most effective way to determine
whether the service member was exposed
to toxins at a specific location what
would be that
criteria that we'd set for the future
ranking member boss we've gone through
this round and round with generations of
the past uh originally folks uh that
were in vietnam were only given it
between certain years and certain
latitudes and they expanded to the brown
water then the blue water there's still
folks that have been exposed to in
thailand cambodia uh guam who don't have
it so trying to piecemeal it out isn't
working
again
exposure synonymous with service we've
got a lot of reports of people on bases
we're not even talking about that people
in hawaii right now are drinking
gasoline
that's terrible we're not even talking
about that in the pack tax so there's
domestic
exposures as well so
military service uh is really what we're
really starting to look towards as
synonymous with exposure
outside of
the individual service member having
monitors
wearing measuring everything they
breathe everything that they're doing
over there
there's no way to truly
track the the exposure dose that an
individual had that's a problem that
earlier generations face they didn't
have any of those measurements to keep
track of the exposure so therefore the
va doesn't think that those troops were
exposed and it takes so long for them to
finally get around to saying well you
may have or like seven years later for
our desert storm veterans when the dod
sent out letters about chemical exposure
and you know by that time most of those
people who were sick were already out of
service then they're trying to get their
claims approved and the va is looking at
them like there's nothing there
and
let me just say this and i'm i'm trying
to work with everybody on this panel and
understand that
but what what you've just said is if you
serve you automatically get it
regardless of where you're at what you
were exposed to anything like that that
changes the whole
process by what we're trying to work on
here because we've got to try to get
something that will pass
through congress which means we have to
have some guidelines set forth i may
even totally agree with you but
trying to get a majority of my
colleagues to do the same we're just
beating a dead horse if we don't come up
with a criteria that's set forth because
that is the standard that's been there
and and
if it's going to be that if you sign the
dotted line you became a member of the
military no matter where you went you
automatically get these benefits then
that's something that we need to look at
but
i don't know how you're going to get it
through and passed okay i understand
that that difficulty and what i
just uh outlined uh mr boss is basically
everyone everywhere at all times but
what we're what we're trying to do is
get it focused where it needs it the
most but i do also want to identify that
frankly there are other things that
we're not talking about we we are
focusing uh a lot on burn pits there's a
lot of other exposures like the men and
women that were at k2 that were like in
a weapons dump right you know so
what i'm trying to identify is like this
is a very pervasive problem uh
throughout the entire military so when
it seems adversarial at va it should
absolutely not be adversarial it should
be a slam dunk it should just be given
that if someone comes in and says i was
exposed the answer should be you bet you
were
um
if you look at the national academy of
science studies in which they would say
we can't draw a conclusion about
exposure to burn pits and the conditions
that we're seeing
even within those studies what they
really say is we have insufficient data
right a lot of the problem here is the
pentagon and dod don't have the
sufficient data and that time has passed
so there's no way to really create a
cohort study the the closest thing we
have to it to go back to 911 is we got
really fortunate in that the fdny had a
cohort study that they had been doing
prior to 9 11. so they had a perfect
lineup of the data of exposure versus
the the pre data
by the the pentagon's own emission
the data that they have is insufficient
and it will never become sufficient
and so what we're doing is we're holding
up
veterans health care and benefits
based on data that the pentagon hasn't
been able to provide
and that will never get better
right
so that's that i think that's the
catch-22 that we've placed the veterans
in because now they're forced to go in
and prove their own case sir even if you
smoke for 20 years if you got lung
cancer
and a doctor and a medical board tried
to make you prove that your lung cancer
came from smoking somebody could always
come in and say well you lived in a city
and you breathed in smog
we have to start living by the code of
the va which is the veteran gets the
benefit of the doubt
it's not causation it's it's
not even correlation
so that i think that's the issue that we
get into as you start to try and define
it which is why i think all the vsos are
talking about presumption being the one
thing that can lift that burden of proof
because the data doesn't actually exist
thank you thank you mr stewart uh mr
geiger i know you've been waiting but mr
trone is back mr trone uh quickly you
can uh are you still here mr trone what
did you leave
if i'm here chairman chicano
thank you i think the veteran gets the
benefit that's the hits the nail on the
head end the story
uh thank you for including the fast the
presumptions act in the bill
uh to get rid of barriers to care and
move this process forward um
two points in business you know we
always took care of our people
and i sit on this committee and also the
veterans appropriations committee where
this is going
and you know we know how crucial it is
to health care and taking care of our
people while our people are our vet so
i'd love to hear
uh from uh mr stewart if we could on two
quick points one is the human cost that
he's talked about a little bit on not
getting this legislation done
that's the cost every day
there's a human cost of not having it
done and the second point is
18 months is that enough time for the va
to implement
we got a covet vaccine and way less
can we do this unless i think we should
i'd love to hear mr stewart lives are at
stake every day
uh sir i mean
what i would say is i think we also have
to start looking at as a national
security issue and i think when you when
you look at how easily defense budgets
go through and the amount of money
that's being spent in the trillions of
dollars that we have spent to try and
rebuild countries overseas while
ignoring
a lot of the pressing issues here i
think you see that
you know our veterans need to know that
when they come home they won't be
discarded staff sergeant isaiah james
who's an infantryman and served in iraq
and afghanistan
said something to me that i think
should should rock all of us to our core
and he said
if another country
was doing to our veterans
what we are doing to our veterans
we would be at war
and that that's just it's a chilling
statement from someone who was boots on
the ground in iraq and afghanistan and
is a young man who has seen a lot of his
colleagues sick and die
and a government that seems relatively
inactive
and and uncaring and not moving and as
far as
uh what the congressman said about the
amount of time for implementation that
should be our entire conversation here
the entire conversation should be
again
how do we implement
first class toxic exposure health care
and prevention and benefits for those
who have served
end of story it's a it we can simplify
this
if we just keep our eye on on the larger
picture
but man you know sergeant wesley black
who rosie brought up earlier
he said in a heartbreaking way it's too
late for me
but i'm going to spend my last
time here on earth advocating for others
so that what happened to me
doesn't happen to any other of my
brothers and sisters and when i go to
meet my maker i'll be able to stand
proud and sadly
he did
uh
unfortunately just a a little while ago
he passed but
you know
we're losing
the battle for hearts and minds of our
own veteran community
and that's unacceptable for a country
that speaks so highly of their veteran
community and purports
uh to love them so much
and and man
you know here's the crazy part
it's so doable
and it's so within reach
within intention and collaboration and
that's what's missing
the va shouldn't be separate from this
process
they shouldn't
this should just be about a
collaboration what the va should be
doing is coming to congress and saying
here are the weak spots in our health
care system
here's how we think we can bolster it
here are the resources we need to do
that and let's move forward together in
it
it can be done
thank you every day it's too late for
one more mom and one more dad
so we got to have a sense of urgency and
trust our veterans they trusted us when
they went to war for us thank you mr
chairman
thank you mr trump uh mr gallego you've
been waiting patiently
thank you and i apologize i have another
markup that's why i i just want to speak
a little look and i i tell you this from
my personal experience i am you know
part of this burn pit community uh i
lived next to one for too long in iraq
and uh
you know i feel like i'm a ticking time
bomb i already have seen friends young
men that have cancer uh brain cancer
different types of cancers rare cancers
and the fact that we're all getting it
uh you know i do feel
i feel scared i mean honestly that you
know every time i go for a checkup that
something is going to be found there
and it does piss me off that we're
hearing about how we're going to pay for
this no one told me anything when i got
sent to iraq in 2005. they just told me
get on the plane and do what the
country's asking for you and we'll take
care of you in return and while i was
there or at least while we were there
this country gave a tax cut to the
richest americans in the country so if
you want to figure out how to pay
for the for us men and women that's i
mean i'll sacrifice our health our youth
our lives basically for this country
then why don't you resend those tax cuts
that were put there while i was at war
taking in rounds and unfortunately now
potentially exposed to
burn pits uh and the cancers and the
diseases that may come uh from that uh
there is plenty of money there was
plenty of money
for us when we cut taxes a couple years
ago under trump there's plenty of money
when we cut taxes under obama there's
plenty of money when we cut taxes under
bush junior
there is plenty of money to take care of
us veterans uh if we wanted to if we
wanted to prioritize and i also want to
point out we will end up doing this
anyway
this is the same thing to happen with
ancient orange we ended up putting it
off for so long that we ended up taking
care of men and women at the end of
their lives when it's actually more
expensive if we actually take care of
the veterans on the front end we could
actually catch a lot of these diseases
early on and actually manage them
because i tell you right now in the end
congress is going to give in it may be
five years from now but there's going to
be five years of people that are being
hurt and it's going to end up costing
the va more so it makes no sense let's
find the paid for
uh if we have to borrow why not borrow
we seem to be able to borrow for tax
cuts that makes no difference
in that plan again i yield back my time
uh thank you uh mr chair and the
witnesses regarding this thank you
thank you mr gallego uh advaith pompey
will be the final word on on this title
mr thompi
good afternoon chairman takano ranking
member boss and members of the committee
the american legion is very grateful for
your commitment to ensure veterans
suffering from illnesses caused by the
toxic
caused by the toxins during their
service have access to this quality va
healthcare
my name is advaithampi and i'm a
legislative associate at the american
legion from 2005 to 2010 i served in the
united states marine corps as a crew
chief on c-130s deploying to iraq in
2008 in afghanistan in 2009 and 10 in
support of the global war on terror
i've witnessed firsthand the near
ubiquitous presence of burn pits in
close proximity to where our troops
slept fought and ate for over 20 years
now
for decades the legion has advocated for
veterans exposed to these toxins such as
agent orange gulf war related hazards
the recent long-awaited passage of the
blue water navy act was the result of
years of advocacy and it came in some
cases 60 years after initial exposure to
the veteran
the american legion will support this
new generation of veterans they are
coming home with illnesses and
conditions caused by airborne toxins
that is a fact period full stop
and we have to act now
um
we keep talking about these costs and
these costs and
like like others have said
um
you know nobody asked about these costs
when we start the war and this has to be
considered a part of the cost of war
the va
has been reactionary they have not
always
been at the forefront and leading on
these they wait for x amount of number
of veterans to pass away from this
exposure and when that number reaches
x amount then they decide to act
from our perspective that's very
reactionary the va is not being
proactive and that's what we hope
that together we can pass this
comprehensive legislation that will
allow for
establishing presumptions of exposure by
establishing a list of presumptive
illnesses associated with exposure and
creating this framework for a
transparency that the va can use to
establish additional presumptive
illnesses in the future
i think what we've all seen is we can't
keep legislating one illness at a time
thank you so much
all right um we'll now move on to the
next title
uh
the next title
is going to be uh
led by uh we'll have the opening uh
discussion
discussion opener led by ms burch
uh you're recognized for to begin our
discussion on title four presumptions of
service connection
thank you for having us today mr
chairman ranking member proposed and
other community members like i said
before i have a toxic exposure
disability um so this issue is very
important to me iava supports the entire
bill
to include the healthcare framework and
presumption of service connection
the presumption piece is
no less critical than the other
components and this piece will finally
lift the burden on the veterans for
proving his or her illnesses
and deserve the approval of the va
the fact is is that presumptions
presumptions help with preventative care
and that it establishes better
preventive care and what doctors can
look for and that preventative care can
help catch these medical problems in the
early stages and therefore not only just
saving a life but saving money
in the long run
you know the war may be over on the
battlefield but the war of combatting
the health and wellness impacts of this
battle has just begun and the emergence
of these impacts will become more
visible as time goes on just like it did
for our vietnam veterans and veterans
from every other war past current and
future veterans
there's a battle at home to be fought to
ensure those who volunteer to serve
their country are taken care of no
matter the cost
again the veteran at the forefront of
the picture
we service members wrote a blank check
to our nation and we're not asking for
the same in return only what is owed to
us the care and services needed to
address the injuries we sustained well
in service those visible and invisible
we must not put any more lives in danger
waiting for a bureaucratic system to
catch up and the time is to act now
for the sake of the current veterans but
also for our future veterans mr chairman
cost wasn't a driver when congress in
the white house sent us to war so we
shouldn't shy away from paying for what
was incurred
thank you miss burch um i just wanted to
inform the members mr lamb and mr ruiz
you are in the queue after a ranking
member myself
for discussion on title four as members
um
uh my first question to uh
you know the group assembled here
is let me just sort of
preface it uh
va does not support
our agent orange presumption expansions
for thailand guam laos and cambodia
stating that
uh these presumption expansions are
inconsistent with dod information
do our does our view are the vsos
present here
agree
with that assessment
no
mr murray vfw says no
yeah no no chair mr chairman the uh the
evidence record does show thailand
did have agent orange experience several
installations through 1976 as well as
johnston atoll which is another location
um where we know e general orange was
exposed so no we don't agree with va
either
so i see mr lehrer thank you mr lehrman
i i saw mr brown uh shake his head yeah
correct vba and vcs a partner we work
with in analyzing this legislation
we strongly agree
and support these expansions of covered
veterans
in section 403 of this legislation
well thank you um i'm going to move to
ranking member boss go ahead and record
member boss
yeah and i've just got one question
because i'm going to listen to the
conversation here but but how can the va
expand its research for
on the health effects of burn pits
exposure how can he
or do we just automatically put into
this title these
these and then say don't expand it
anymore just
accept these and then are we still
looking or what do we
i'm trying to figure
you know
as we try to get this passed as i said
earlier we've got to make sure that we
have answers
and and and just going ahead and writing
the check
is is something that maybe we would all
agree on this panel
but
we still got to get it through everybody
else that's what i'm trying to figure
out here so
well
i'm sorry mr
mr liberalized who smith who else wants
to comment uh
well i'll start with you mr go ahead
well i i think part of it is
va can accept science outside of the
national academies and their own
evidence
absolutely they can it's actually even
written into the statutes for agent
orange exposure as well for undiagnosed
illnesses and others so
i think looking at other places is a
first grade step and then to your point
finding a way to do some comprehensive
studies on those who were exposed that
way we can add potentially more in the
future if needed beyond what we have but
i think va already has the authority to
look outside
of the national academies
they just need to exercise right
uh you know i did
miss miss torres i did see your comment
in the chat about
the 911
model
uh
being a good model to look at
i also want to just clarify in addition
to either qualifications the packed act
would provide concession to airborne
hazards
uh and access to healthcare for certain
gulf war and post 9 11 veterans based on
dates and locations just want to clarify
that
uh
anything anybody else want to respond to
the ranking i think
ranking member boss if i hear you
correctly if i hear you accurately
you're concerned that maybe these these
presumptions
kind of show up maybe as little as as
without rhyme or reason somewhat
arbitrary like you're just sort of
plucking them out of the air but i don't
think that's the case
i didn't mean it that way but as we're
moving forward we put these down and
then okay what what do we use for
research what standard do we put how do
we
how do we get uh
as we try to uh if we're not going down
the path of saying what we that came up
in the discussion earlier that
automatically when you're enlisted from
here on out you're going to be covered
that's just the way it is we're going to
assume that everybody was exposed what
are what's the criteria we're going to
use how do we encourage the va to use
certain criteria what uh
you know we don't want to go down the
path of blue water navy and we don't
want to go down the path of agent orange
and we don't want i i i disagree with
one person that said a while ago that it
saved would save some money by doing it
earlier it actually unfortunately with
blue water navy it didn't it it
it wouldn't have saved them money by
doing it earlier because they waited
until two-thirds of them died off before
they were able to even provide the
benefit so
that's not the way we want to do it
either so uh
i'm just trying to figure that you know
mr boss might could just someone could
chime in and some of our vso partners or
other members but what i recall is that
the
the most prevalent respiratory
presumptions
had a lot of scientific basis to them
for the from the academies and the
secretaries moved forward with three of
the more prevalent respiratory uh
presumptions the rare cancers because
they are rare
uh and they're happening in very young
people
uh
that
uh
i mean
they're frankly not gonna be they're not
as prevalent because of the definition
of their being rare uh so
anyway i want to move on to mr lamb uh
mr william go ahead
thank you mr chairman um
i just wanted to say one thing based on
our recent experiences in this committee
and i was hoping maybe our witness from
vba could respond to this
i represent a very large chapter of
vietnam veterans of america and worked
with them closely on
the agent orange presumptions and
frankly as someone that's 37 years old i
was shocked when i got to congress and
found out that we were still trying to
establish
new agent orange presumptions almost 50
years or more than 50 years in some
cases after the exposure took place
the post 9 11
veterans community that has has grown
and is represented on this call
just like the vva veterans groups are
never going to give up on this issue i
want to make sure everyone all the
members understand that people who are
voicing
concerns about the cost and the pace and
that kind of thing like they're going to
keep fighting for these people even god
forbid as some of them pass away and
that'll make them fight harder so yes we
lost a lot of blue water navy veterans
before the presumption finally came into
effect but that is going to make the
veterans community work harder and
harder and harder to establish
these presumptions um they're not giving
up and so in a lot of ways i think this
discussion of
you know what is the exact standard how
we're going to do it when we're going to
do with the pace is a little bit
academic this is happening the american
public supports this i mean mr stewart
said america loves veterans in a
specific way we know that the american
public will support this because
eventually they got there on agent
orange we don't need it to take that
long we can all see what direction this
is going and that's why i think it makes
sense to act now the whole purpose of a
presumption is that we are saying there
is in exactitude here and the tie goes
to the veteran so to the extent that i
have a question
mr brown i just wanted to ask if if you
were i don't know if anyone had ever
done a a study or a
calculation of all that was lost in the
time that vietnam veterans were waiting
for
um you know benefits for hypertension
and hypothyroid and all the different
things that you've had to fight for even
in recent years bladder cancer um but if
you could fill us in on on maybe the
cost of of waiting uh so that this
committee understands how how stupid it
is for us to try to punt this further
down the field
well the cost of waiting
uh how do you put a cost on a life
somebody who served this country is
dying from different types of cancers
rare cancers
uh from exposures they were
exposed to on their deployments
and
i mean i don't know how you put a cost
on a life for people that the government
sent in the harm's way to start with
i mean i i can't begin to
understand that concept or to
uh see how you can properly put a cost
on an individual's life
what i can tell you
concerning title 4
is that
va for the last 15 years va's own
research has shown significant increases
in hypertension among herbicide exposed
veterans
even giving existing framework for
adding new herbicide presumptive
conditions va failed to do so
this should serve as a powerful
cautionary tale
to uh the ugly optimistic opponents for
creating a new one-size-fits-all but
doesn't framework that leaves the va in
the driver's seat
in this legislation we most strongly
support the provision for added name
presumptive conditions
thank you thank you mr brown and thank
you mr lamb um
my two like you have a huge vietnam
veterans of america chapter in my area
um
and uh was shocked as you were uh dr
ruiz um i'm sure you have plenty to say
on this topic uh uh you're i'm calling
you next
thank you mr chairman and thank you to
all the bsos and the leadership and the
veterans that are out there
for your tremendous steadfast work your
perseverance and your strong leadership
look
this is a very important title
that we need to discuss this is the crux
the soul
of the bill
it is based on a bill
that you all work together uh to produce
uh it's the presumptive benefits for war
fighters exposed to burn pits and other
toxins act it is a bipartisan and
bicameral bill that originated from our
veteran communities uh and we're moving
it forward as now title four of this
important bill it is the soul of
honoring our pact act it is the vital
organ that keeps this patient alive in
order to ensure that we give the care
and the benefits that the veterans need
and their widowed spouses who are
relying on this it is the part that
addresses the family as well but before
i continue to go there i just want to
review some of the excuses that i've
been hearing over and over and over
first is this wait a minute we need to
do more research on this because it goes
back to the original excuse that there's
not enough evidence look guys i've said
over and over clarifying this
misinformation
there is enough evidence to suggest that
toxic burn pit smoke
can produce
illnesses in the lungs and cancers and
autoimmune diseases
carcinogens cause cancer
burn pit toxic smoke contains cancer
they've identified uh
carcinogens in the soil
burnt exposed veterans are developing
cancer where the how do you think they
got it from
okay it's very it's very straightforward
there's enough evidence from
extrapolating from firefighters who are
exposed to 1911 and jet fuel that was
that was burnt there is enough evidence
in our own u.s environmental research
that has already banned burn pits from
being conducted in our backyards or as
industries in the united states
so there is enough evidence with a high
enough suspicion that burn kids are
causing this illnesses and we don't have
to go beyond the scientific papers we
can just listen to our veterans and our
veterans widows who are crying out over
and over again who say that they have no
other risk factors that they're
absolutely healthy and now they're dying
or they're dead from all these different
illnesses the other the other
excuse has been that oh this will be too
much of a strain for the
institution these are unfunded mandates
and we don't know how the institution
are going to handle it it is our
responsibility to fund what our veterans
need and we must do that for our
veterans
that strain in the institution argument
is from individuals who put the
institution first
and i'm telling you we must put our
veterans first we must give our veterans
and be veteran-centric veterans focused
and take care of our veterans like we
take care of our patients in the
emergency department that i know of
quite well the other excuse is that we
cost too much it costs too much money
now listen
that's a value statement
and i don't know about you all but my
value is to put people first
is to make sure that our veterans are
taking care of my value
instead of giving tax breaks in the
tunes of millions and billions to one
percent rich individual families in our
nation is to give the veterans the care
that they need because they need it
right now before they're dying the other
excuse is that
the pace is too fast
the pace is too fast
this is ridiculous
ask the widows of our veterans
if it was if we're moving too fast
as folks like leroy and others who are
suffering from constrictive
bronchiolitis who are 100 percent oxygen
dependent
and therefore unable to care for their
family work or others if we're moving
too fast
when i hear and veterans hear that the
pace is too fast what they're hearing is
that they want to delay until dead just
like what happened with agent orange and
our vietnam veterans
and so
look since i've heard about this i've
been getting real-time feedback from the
veterans in my district
and i want to tell you about alejandro
camacho of palm desert who is a veteran
who answered the call to duty
while serving in south sinjar iraq
alejandro breathed in toxic fumes
particular matter and carcinogens from
the batteries medical jet fuel and other
military
items that were disposed of in large
burn pits on his base
when he returned home he noticed that
that his breathing in the fumes had
caused a toll on his body he was later
diagnosed with aggressive form of
testicular cancer
despite his doctor's belief that his
diagnosis will link to his exposure to
burn pits the va denied his claim
because they said quote there wasn't
enough evidence unquote
i have a palm desert councilwoman here
karina quintanilla who tells me that her
head her ex-husband
is still having
constant coughing chronic coughing
illnesses after being
deployed in the middle east
ms burch have you heard from members of
your organization that have been
diagnosed with cancer that their doctors
believe is linked to burn pit exposure
and where and their claims were denied
by the va
yes uh we've heard from numerous members
and through our survey that reaches
thousands and thousands of veterans
across the country
that there are plenty of veterans right
now that are getting denied benefits
that have cancer rare cancer and
and you look at these veterans and
they're young like me i'm 34 i look
healthy right i'm not i've got all kinds
of medical issues and they push you to
the side and say oh well you can't have
cancer you know you're young you're
healthy and then later you know they
find out later oh well you did have
cancer we don't know how you got it but
now it's stage four and well well good
luck
yeah uh sadly this is a common theme
throughout our veterans story what we
need is to end the excuses to take care
of our veterans to pass the honoring our
pac-tac and making sure that uh that the
uh presumptive benefits for warfighters
section in this title iv is maintained
for those of you who think that this is
the way we're going to save cause or
nickel and dime our veterans by
eliminating some of the cancers or
pulmonary illnesses that are listed in
this list i have news for you you will
not go and attempt this without
resistance or without a fight because
this is what's going to save lives this
is what's going to bring justice to the
widows who are currently suffering
trying to raise their families and we
will fight two canals to make sure that
this section is maintained
thank you doctor
mr brown i got to give the last word to
on this section on this section uh to uh
mr field who's been waiting patiently um
so uh thank you dr ruiz uh thank you for
clarifying this issue about the rare
cancers
by definition their ricker uh and
uh
the the the more expensive presumptions
are already are currently being dealt
with by the va the respiratory
presumptions
so uh
mr field go ahead
john are you are you still with us
did he go
he might have had to uh to run out to do
something he had some 911 business that
he that he had to do but to to drive
home his point
uh i'm going to give you guys the worst
case scenario for presumption the worst
case for presumption is simply this
but somewhere along the line
the va will pay the health cost and
benefit
for someone who sacrificed and fought
for this country for their colon cancer
and it turns out that their colon cancer
wasn't necessarily caused by a burn but
maybe it was caused by bacon that's your
worst
case
scenario
in terms of of
presumption you know the va
and and and this body have to remove
their blinders
the evidence on the carcinogens that are
in this smoke is overwhelming
in in medical papers outside of the
national academy
it all exists and the 9 11 health and
compensation program exists as well as a
model
and one that is a blueprint that could
easily be followed
if the will was there
it works it's effective it honors the
taxpayers it's not wasteful it's not
fraudulent it doesn't fail audits like
the pentagon does
so
uh if you're looking for a responsible
program that can help finally address
the toxic exposure issues that so many
in the veterans community have suffered
for so many years it's there
well thank you mr stewart um
i now want to move on to title
uh five and i want to thank you all for
the discussion on title four
um and uh
i i now call on mr uh
tampy
uh to begin our discussion on title five
on research matters mr tampa go ahead
all right thank you so much chairman
takano and thank you again ranking
member boss and members of this
committee for taking the time to listen
to us all here so title 5 authorizes va
to conduct scientific research that will
impact veterans and their families
affected both today and in the future if
our military sent to areas with airborne
toxins or hazards it's critical for va
to understand how toxic exposures will
affect veterans currently suffering from
illnesses that have yet to be identified
at the va at this time
the va will lead coordinating authority
toxic exposure related studies and
establish a strategic plan to ensure
that the research is collaborative
transparent and coordinated with
oversight being provided by hvac and as
fat committees
at one point i just want to make um
before turning it over the va
has a reputation
of being reactionary and when trying to
provide care for veterans in the past
we just we can't let
we can't wait for another 40 years
before this generation of the global war
and terror veterans to receive their
health care
paradigm shift must must occur to
transform the va so they can tackle
toxic exposures in the future
being proactive this research is what
allows them to determine
what common illnesses are affecting gulf
war veterans today what common cancers
are post-9 11 veterans going to get in
10 years in 15 years where
the studies relating to cancers that are
determined to be positively associated
with identify toxic exposure veterans
and then we have to think about the
families and the dependents of veterans
and the feasibility of providing champa
benefits to those dependents for
healthcare costs
um
all that were
the main goal of this section is to have
allow va to have that crown jewel of
research that they do have and this
section is what allows them to do that
thank you so much
thank you mr tampee um i'll begin with
my question
under title
five
um
so the va requests that we strike our
dependent health care study
stating that no science or evidence has
been
found by the nascm
that
connects adverse health outcomes of a
dependent or an individual in utero with
exposures unique to the veteran
is this a study worth pursuing on behalf
of our veteran dependents
um quick reactions
yes yes
so i'm not seeing any any of our vso say
it's not uh it's not a worthy study um
so i'm going to just move on to ranking
member box go ahead and rank your boss
thank you mr chairman and audrey i just
want you to expand on this this is
actually directed towards you because i
think you mentioned it in your your
opening there do you believe va has been
aggressive enough to pursue the research
regarding the health effects of toxic
exposures
with what they've done so far
ranking member boss
um it is my
it's my personal opinion that um
while
the va has made attempts um
we
[Music]
the american legion
uh believes that the efforts could be
more
uh
there could be um
there could be more efforts to be more
collaborative with the vso community
including us in on
um the pilot study would have been
something that i think we all would have
really appreciated um
a lot
we want to
we we
we had those at the va and we within the
vso communities we're both trying to
help veterans we know that and
we understand that they're a partner at
the end of the day they are our partners
and we have to work with them
um so i don't want to come off as being
disrespectful or rude um but um
that we do believe that their efforts
could be more collaborative and more
transparent
yeah
i think that many members believe that
too but yeah go ahead i'm sorry again uh
thank you sir uh
i think uh one thing is that not coming
too hard on down on the va but thinking
a little bit outside the box is that the
va
we
consistently talk about how overworked
they are that they don't have time it's
playing catch-up
well what about
working within the community i'm a big
fan of community over competition right
how many medical skills do we have in
this country and eager medical medical
students to that want to research that
want to get their hands into these
things and so why not work with local
medical schools i mean you have national
jewish health cu johns hopkins the list
goes on right and work together with the
va and to remove some of that burden on
the va in hopes that the research can
come along quicker to make sure that the
research is now backing up
the healthcare needs of veterans and
making sure that they're being taken
care of and then one other point was
that
i keep hearing you say you know
everyone's looking for the solution what
do we do and well
although we can't
you know veterans that are already
outside of active duty service it's
going to be harder to go back and get to
them however we still have active duty
service members still serving that we're
exposed to burn pits and one idea that
i've kind of shot around in my head is
that when i was getting out in the
military i had to go through i went
through a medical board because i was
retired right well they do a scan they
tell you what's going on we'll have
questions to ask these members are you
experiencing this
so the other thing is that they do
x-rays well i had an x-ray on my chest
because i had been exposed and prior
coughing and and so forth and so
that x-ray showed this nodule that i had
no idea was there next thing i know i'm
getting scans and all this stuff and so
many veterans are getting out of the
military without any of that
preventative screening or seeing what's
going on within their bodies
and because i did they could go back and
service connect and i got my disability
well so many other veterans don't show
start showing symptoms until afterwards
but if they had that percent you know
specific screening that wouldn't be the
case and they wouldn't be getting denied
their benefits so why don't we lean you
know lay the framework for this
preventative stuff and this screening
that at least helps some of the veterans
that were exposed to toxic exposure now
instead of
uh retroactively all right that's a good
idea
are you back
thank you thank you very much uh mr mr
vale
uh
thank you mr chairman um
the ba would like to say that
um you know more needs to be done as far
as research to establish presumptions
and
you know it's not exactly career
enhancing for a researcher va to find
research uh to support more benefits
uh we think morning is done at va and
also these presumptives are crucial our
vietnam vets don't have a whole lot of
time left you look at the age of our
vietnam vets and the poor health that
they're in
and they don't have time to fight
an appeal to win their claim uh the bva
we just won
a thailand at four hundred thousand
dollars he's been fighting this for 25
years
and we tried to go the direct service
connection route and they kept denying
it
more more denials we had to take it up
to the board and our vietnam vets don't
have time to go to the board and the
presumption is easier to grant than
direct service connection
and it eliminates many shades of gray
that exist like for example for for
being getting service connected for
thailand uh the current the current uh
rules are it's
it's too complicated and the raiders
don't want to take a risk and granting
it asking a vso how many times we've
been told oh well i can't grant this if
you want it granted you have to go to
the board because the board has more
authority to grant
i have a memo from ogc that says
otherwise the board and the ros have the
same authority to grant but these
raiders that there's a corporate culture
at va they do not want to grant timeline
agent orange claims but again our
vietnam vets are running out of time
they don't have time to fight an appeal
at the board so
we bba fully supports section 403 for
for these presumptions because it makes
it easier
to service connect and the raiders i've
i've audited raiders ros and they've
told me when i come to work i don't
think
what can i do in the best service
veteran i come to work thinking how can
i maximize the points for this claim
to so i can meet my quarters so i don't
get fired
and
and so the easier you make it for the
raider to make their points the more
likely you are to get a grant and that's
why these presumptions are so helpful
and so important and and lastly the um
again we support the uh section 403 um i
yield back my time thank you
i
i have a question if you don't mind
chairman
quickly go ahead mr brown yes uh
this this is going back to the uh the
previous title uh 403
vietnam veterans of america and dcs uh
we do not support changing the current
framework for vietnam veterans
presumptive making process that's
currently on the books
this new uh under the honor our pact act
uh it leaves a more restrictive
presumptive making policy
and um we feel that uh
you know
looking at like i mentioned that study
earlier for 15 years the va had
a study showing hypertension and higher
rates in vietnam herbicide exposed
veterans
they never acted upon that study even
though it clearly it's grown research
and
lastly from the same section in the
honor in our
section 405 concerning gulf war veterans
uh for the most part
uh this section uh
uh
bba and vcs do support however
we need to find out
what comes from
the high denial rates of the gulf war
veteran presumptive claims that's been
going on for 20 years and is well
documented
what what will this legislation do
to address that we met with this
committee
before the pandemic took place and shut
right before they shut down capitol hill
and we were promised a round table to
address that matter and it never came it
never came fructation
so
uh just because we're adding
presumptives
is the va going to be able to
do these presumptives where it's still
not leading to a 73 denial rate like
with the gulf war veterans chronic
multi-symptom illness presumptives and a
93 denial rate for uh the undiagnosed
illness presumptive for them
all right all right well thank thank you
mr brown duly noted really notable uh
your uh
uh input uh from vba will be death that
will do unloaded i'm gonna now move on
uh to the next uh
title
ranking yes i'd like to first off
apologize to everyone i have a hard stop
i've got to get to another area i'm
really this is vitally important um
we're going to continue to monitor this
and and uh i appreciate that the time
that we've had today uh and i apologize
that i have to leave i thank you for
your interest and i thank you and i know
your staff is with us
and taking in all the information as
well so i i appreciate your
participation mr boss all right um we
did then we move on to uh ms
uh to uh title
six
and lindsay i know you were in the queue
to comment perhaps you can combine your
comments with uh
um at this at the end of your uh
discussion opener
on title six
so uh lindsay you're recognized uh to
open up discussion on title six and
maybe to add some more of your comments
uh generally
fantastic thank you chairman takana
ranking member boasts a member of the
committee
mba is grateful for the work this
committee is doing to address toxic
exposure we believe that toxic exposure
should not be a byproduct of service but
since it is its impact to a driver
excuse me it's
imperative to address to the issue with
healthcare plus benefits without delay
as part of the honoring our pact act is
the improvement of resources and
training regarding toxic exposed
veterans
the importance of these provisions
cannot be understated we can change or
we can make the best and most sound
policy but without the ability to
implement these changes agency-wide and
get information to veterans in places
they need it most we will be building
these policies in vain
our members continue to report denial of
their claims for toxic exposure-related
illnesses and from being added to the
burn pit registry sometimes waiting
years for their claims to even be
reviewed then even more in appeals
trying to overturn these decisions these
delays and denials are not just time
consuming and frustrating they can take
place as a veteran as veterans are
fighting off illnesses that could very
well take their lives in the meantime
additionally included in this provision
is outreach to veterans regarding
benefits we urge that concerted efforts
be focused on reaching hard to reach and
underserved veteran communities mainly
minority veterans who have been
disenfranchised or who have been
deterred from even applying for benefits
based on information from their peers
about their denial
given that many minority veterans even
in the absence of burn pits are already
at increased risk for cancer for many
cancers and other illnesses and that
whole minority veterans were stationed
at places like fort mcclellan alabama
outreach and getting this information
into their hands can can and will save
lives
um in section 505 uh we wanted to
address the fact that there is age and
gender but grace is not included in this
in the research we believe it's
imperative for two reasons one because
many minority veterans specifically
racial ethnic minority veterans are more
likely to already have an increased
propensity for contract for developing
cancer and other other related illnesses
we need to include race in this in this
conversation to ensure that we're
looking at this from the research
perspective in addition you also have
higher rates of veterans and minority
veterans who are in combat roles where
they are more likely to be exposed to
these toxic chemicals so adding race as
a provision in the research is
imperative to understanding the whole
picture
uh in addition sorry i'm not very
aggressive so i didn't get in there
early in the conversation but going back
to ranking member boasts question about
whether or not we provide health care
now and benefits and have this
conversation later um yes it's important
and nobody's gonna hear is gonna
disagree that we need to be providing
health care for these issues no one here
is gonna disagree about that but looking
at history from the minority veteran
perspective every time that something is
rolled out without direct and
intentional design minority veterans are
left out so if we continue to do this
we're going to see higher rates of
higher rates of denial among minority
veterans and less access for minority
veterans if we don't design this with
very specific intention so it's our
opinion that you absolutely have to be
doing this with intention and not just
rolling out benefits to say we're going
to meet the stock gap right now we want
to see that happen but so many people
are being turned away then who are we
actually serving and going back to mr
stewart's comment about the national
security issue you're 100 correct
service relies on trust military
veterans have to trust the institution
in order to keep going i'm a third
generation service member do you think
that i'm going to tell my child to serve
after i've seen this absolutely not if
my parents or my or my grandparents had
seen that this conversation they would
have told me the same you're going to
limit the number of people that are able
to serve in the military in addition
as a veteran myself i served and i was
told i have to follow and obey lawful
orders who is making the dod do this if
there isn't if there's a provision that
says that you can't have burn pits in
the united states of america why are
united states troops being exposed to
these in other areas who is making sure
that the department of defense is
following those same lawful orders that
you're asking us to uphold it is not
fair and we all know that the dod is
responsible for paying for this if we
can't from the veterans benefits we have
to make sure that somebody is paying for
this we didn't it was not our fault we
followed lawful orders and we were told
if we're going to get sent somewhere if
we're going to go somewhere that the dod
is telling us to go we're going to
follow a lot for orders if we had walked
away we would have been as a deserter we
would have ended ruling out ruining our
lives and getting dishonorable
discharges because we walked away we
didn't have a choice people were all
stuck there they were stuck walking left
they were you continue to hear people
that say i was ready to die for my
country but i didn't think it would
happen five years after dying from
cancer
that's our community's legacy that is
911's legacy and we have to do better in
order to keep that trust to keep that
national security intact if we can
afford to send people to war we can take
care of those warriors when they come
back home in a culture that celebrates
veterans so deeply
thank you chairman
well thank you miss church
wow that was very powerful um
you know with your adult with the
indulgence of the group here i would
like to get mr titus to uh
uh open up discussion on title seven so
we can do title seven and title six
together
um and then um i did see members that
had their hands raised
mr elsie uh you're in the queue for that
so i'll be calling on you after i call
mr titus mr ty just go ahead and begin
our discussion on open up our discussion
on title
thank you chairman um and uh thank you
ranking member boston members of the
hvac we appreciate you holding this
roundtable discussion discuss toxic
exposures and honoring our pact mo
believes that comprehensive toxic
exposure reform is long overdue and we
applaud the committee's dedication to
this issue
we support the honoring our pact act and
i appreciate the opportunity to share
our thoughts on title vii
the section on health registries and
records
this title takes several important steps
to increase awareness and capture data
old and new on toxic exposures
section 701 creates a health register
for per and polyfluoroalkalized
substances as we and as we learn more
about the harms of pfas and the
prevalence of exposures within our
community a health registry is vital to
ensure the resources for us
vital resources for service members and
veterans
section 702 shows us why it establishes
a health registry for individuals
stationed at fort mcclellan
while va recognizes that there's over 60
or 67 disposal sites at fort mccall and
the current contained a variety of toxic
substances that service members and
their families were exposed to over the
years va has not recognized any health
adverse health effects
from those
were there creating a registry is an
important step to gather data on the
health conditions of those who served
under a variety of circumstances
section 703 and 704 require reporting on
eiler and collecting this information is
important because ensures an
understanding of all the exposure
service members facing and this section
requires regular reporting on the
effectiveness and accuracy of the data
the data that is vital to oversight
efforts here eiler can be helpful to
service members and veterans and we are
encouraged by the transparency and
oversight offered by these sections
however it's important to remember
because of the nature of war there will
always be exposure data limitations and
we should not hold either data gaps
against veterans and this is why section
705 is so important and this which
provides a path for service members and
veterans to correct their insp exposure
records we should be empowering veterans
and service members to provide a way for
them to interact with their health
records
and other has a lot of potential to do
so and what we need to make sure is this
is
linked and connected throughout the dod
in a in an effective way
the sections in title vii work to
address veterans uh overlooked for
generations and provide a path forward
to learn from our mistakes and better
care for future generations so we
encourage these elements are included if
the cost or the honoring or packed act
is pass or any comprehensive reform
efforts
so thank you chairman
well thank you uh
mr titus
um i see uh
uh
miss kieran uh from miss keenan ms
keenan ms keenan from the vfw um
[Music]
you like to comment on either title
uh thank you chairman takano uh
christina keenan vfw just filling in for
for pat murray who had to step away um
on on title seven i think
what it what this really does is
recognizes that toxic exposures can even
occur on domestic military installations
um and and you know it's just sort of
uh touching back to title ii and
improving the framework in which va
recognizes presumptives that's so it's
so critical because there will be new
exposures there are already new
exposures
um and so
this entire comprehensive package is
is so critical because there are going
to be things that we need to address in
the future and and title seven is is
really starting to point towards what
those new things um already are
thank you
thank you miss keenan um i uh mr mr
moroski go ahead
thank you mr chairman uh just to comment
on title six which is the training um i
think that this title doesn't
necessarily get as much attention as
some of the other ones that we've talked
about so far but uh it's extremely
important
for health care providers to have better
training on toxic exposures which i
think rosie talked about earlier but
also for veterans benefits
administration personnel to get better
training on toxic exposures you know the
culture at va has been brought up a
couple of times and when it comes to
toxic exposure claims um you know it's
one of quite frankly denial um
you know the vba is pretty good the the
veteran's disability claim system works
pretty well
uh on most things uh except for toxic
exposures um you know i've used this
analogy before that um you know
if a claims adjudicator looks at a claim
of a person who was uh you know a
parachute jumper
and says hey look you've got you know 50
parachute training jumps and now you've
got bad knees they're willing to uh you
know make the connection and say that
yes
as likely as not your bad knees were
caused by your parachute jumps but when
they look at somebody who is exposed to
a burn pit for two years and then they
have pancreatic cancer
they're not willing to say they say well
you may have had may have had the
pancreatic cancer anyway um you know we
need to make sure that vba personnel
know that they can
grant those claims uh you know and and
in the same way that they grant claims
for for physical disability so i just
wanted to make that point sir thank you
thank you mr moroski um mr elsie um
you're recognized
thank you mr chairman brothers and
sisters uh from the military all
veterans thank you for joining us today
the work you're gonna be that you've
done today the sacrifices you have made
are going to improve health care for
uh my children when my son when he
becomes a veteran when he goes into the
military and enters combat this is about
the next war as well
and your sacrifices are not going to be
unnoticed this is a very emotional topic
mr stewart thanks for all your advocacy
both for uh me and our veterans and the
911 commission you you have uh improved
the lives of many given a great deal of
attention to this very serious subject i
want to point out the fact that
going forward there's a there's a degree
of responsibility that dod does have
we they do a great job of recruiting
training sending to war
all of uh the young men and women who
choose to serve they don't train you to
be a civilian and when they kick you out
they say there's the va good luck
godspeed we're all counting on you that
has got to change no veteran should
become a veteran without first receiving
a complete medical work up of all the
problems that they have beforehand
before they become civilian day one
until that occurs it is incumbent on the
military when we do go into combat you
are exposed to whether you're on an
aircraft carrier where you're dropping
bombs whether you're getting shot at
ingesting all different kinds of
chemicals and gases
the military must do a better job the
medics that you're working with on the
ground must be annotating these forays
into combat in which you're exposed to
things because right now the
responsibility is on the va and the
veteran themselves to point out what
they've been exposed to we can no longer
accept that any comment we go into from
here forward must be incumbent on the
dod and the medics and the officers that
are in charge of all their troops going
into combat to say
we were exposed take him right now noted
in the medical record so that when you
step out of your military time you will
be taken care of and we won't have to
have these conversations anymore
so i yield back thank god for all of you
thanks for your sacrifices i'm sorry if
any of you have had any uh difficulties
with the va
dod owes you a lot more too and we need
to fix that problem so thanks to all of
you i yield back thank you miss chairman
i appreciate your sentiments mr elsie
and
hopefully we can get you on the bill um
is any i see mr titus
do you have a response or comment mr
tattis
um i just want to add one more thing mr
chairman in regards to talking about the
research
matters
and title v
this is a lifelong
situation when our service members are
exposed to toxic substances we need to
continue the efforts to continue
following the research throughout their
entire lives to paint the picture a
study came out just last year about the
increased risk of dementia for service
members exposed agent orange decades
prior
so i think that we need to continue to
follow these issues through
throughout service members lives and
through uh to the next generation of
potential service members as well thank
you
thank you uh mr mervan
cameron
chairman takano i want to thank you very
much for this opportunity i want to
thank all the veterans for being here
and for sharing your stories and for
advocating uh for our american veterans
that being said it is a matter of
priority and intentions as mr stewart
had talked about and how we value our
veterans and provide them the benefits
necessary
i don't believe now is the time to
nickel and dime on issues and that are a
matter of life and death for our
american veterans
uh and i also want to
emphasize the value of
making sure that
we give the most effective efficient
ways
necessary to be able to benefit our
veterans and how we do that in the speed
in which we can to be able to serve them
and ultimately
i'm brought back to a time uh
during the fourth of july
right after we passed this piece of
legislation uh before the cbo came back
and i was in a parade uh and was able to
speak to many veterans and was able to
talk about you know the benefits that
are necessary and there were many
stories of people who stopped me
where they weren't quite sure what was
affecting them but they knew something
was wrong and so this piece of
legislation
uh the honoring our
our pact act
makes sure we don't leave veterans
behind
with that
as chairman of the subcommittee on
technology modernization
i've been reviewing the va's i.t
investment to include those made in the
vba
it's my understanding that when benefits
were expanded to the blue water navy
veterans exposed to the agent orange vba
struggle
vba struggled to manage the surge in
claims and required an increase in
infrastructure and in it support funding
to enable faster processing of veterans
claims
ms keenan from the vfw and lindsay if
you could
i would like to hear your perspectives
regarding va's ability to execute on
this important legislation
we have not made enough of an investment
to modernize the veterans benefit
management system and i want to support
va in providing the benefits
included in the pact act
and this is a an all-encompassing if you
can answer that question perspective
i'll i'll just jump in christina from
the vfw
um as as part of the independent budget
uh vsos we we are planning to recommend
um additional funding for vba to
modernize and upgrade their their i.t
systems in order to deal with the
current backlog of claims and for the
potential future uh increase in toxic
exposure claims um this is likely a
multi-year project project
but we are making those formal
recommendations through
the independent budget with our partners
at pva and dav
so we
also support the recommendation to
increase the uh budget and increase the
capacity of vba to address these claims
we recognize um we're hearing from
members across the board that they're
waiting four and a half years there's 80
000 people in front of them that they
don't know how long it's going to take
that they're getting denied
and we also know at the same time that
va's technology infrastructure is
lacking severely in decades behind and
so in order to make this happen we need
to be building those structures now to
be able to best support when this
actually does pass and when this goes
through because
we can't use the surge of claims as an
as an excuse for not moving this
legislation forward va has to be making
those investments now they already know
that this is an issue so we have to be
prioritizing this to ensure that the
capacity is grown of va to be able to
address these claims 80 000 people after
four and a half years is absurd um so
making sure that people have the ability
to get through this process in their
lifetimes which may or may not be four
and a half
years you miss church um i'm going to
call on mr brown and mr hawthorne uh
mr brown go ahead quickly yes
to give you an example of
of how difficult these rare cancers are
to get service connected i work directly
with two different va secretaries
secretary bob mcdonald and secretary dr
david shulkins
to get a brain cancer presumptive based
upon
va's own research for gulf war veterans
they pushed this all the way to the
office of management and budget and it
was denied in 2016
and then dr shulkins did the same
in 2017 and it was denied so
you know even with the research and va
wanting to do the right thing
you had other agencies who didn't see
fit to grant the funding for them
thank you for bringing that up mr brown
it was a member of his omb it was not it
was technically an agency but omb is
basically the tool of the the president
at the time
so uh i thank you for bringing that
example up
um
uh mr cawthorn uh go ahead
uh mr chairman thank you very much
ranking member boss thank you mr stewart
all of our representatives from all
these great organizations i appreciate
you all being here uh i'd like to direct
this question to miss miss keenan with
the uh
with the vfw or lindsay or alex
uh when would you believe is the ideal
time to let veterans know
when they are eligible and what benefits
they are eligible for when it is in
regards to burn pits is that before they
leave the service is i mean i think mr
elzie brought up a great point of
really
enlightening and informing these these
soldiers and these marines and these
sailors about when they're leaving the
service to become veterans uh when they
should learn about all of these uh these
ideas so i'll open the floor to anyone
who wants to answer that
um i'll just jump in very quickly um i
mean
you know during the tap program is is
definitely not too early um the vfw does
have uh you know accredited service
officers on military installations to
help facilitate um you know
applying for their benefits even before
they're discharged
um but you know the earlier the better i
mean
what some of the complaints that we've
heard with veterans in regards to va is
just the lack of information
whether it's through email through
technology or or just at the va
on what their benefits are and what they
can do if they believe that they were
exposed to toxic substances so there
really isn't a point of time that is too
early whether it's in service as they're
transitioning or right at their first
point of contact with the department of
veterans affairs
but i'll jump in real quick um i i agree
that it should happen at the very latest
as they're transitioning from service
but in honesty as a veteran myself i
would say before they go on deployment
um we should be talking about toxic
exposure before anybody's exposed we
should have options like veterans don't
like i said in the beginning we don't
have an option to walk away from post we
don't have an option to walk away from a
burn pit but we should we should have
options when it comes to whether or not
we're willing to go in and expose
ourselves so before before getting
exposed and if it happens while you're
on deployment or while you're in in
theater you should be told when you're
leaving and from there you should only
be told more because that's going to
that's going to increase prevention and
early detection because what's happening
now is people get four and a half 10
years into their survey or attend their
post post exposure and they're dying why
are we not looking at this 10 years ago
when they were exposed and making sure
that they have all the tools that they
need to manage what's coming you know
like they shouldn't be caught off guard
by cancer or as like
asthma or something that they weren't
expecting when dod and va knew full well
15 years ago
thank you miss church i'm going to go to
mr lehrman his hand was up first and
then
uh mr tampa your hand was up under mr
brown uh mr liman go ahead
uh thank you chairman i greatly
appreciate it i just want to make a
comment reference to what representative
morvan was talking about uh va
it infrastructure
that's very important they could hire 10
000 more people to help but if we don't
have the tools to expedite the process
now we're going to be in a world of hurt
there's over 200 000 pending backlog
claims today
so in a heavy investment in
va's infrastructure i.t systems and just
a point what we saw yesterday
the automation
that is being tested out in uh
at the boise va regional office for
increased claims
we should be heavily investing in that
in va so that we one don't have backlog
claims and two we never have to hear
well we can't take care of that because
va doesn't have the resources and
infrastructure we should be
paying ahead so the system is set up to
handle whatever comes its way and tax
exposed veterans stop paying the price
thank you mr lairman on what he's
talking about there chairman with
technology and capacity
yes mr champion go ahead
[Music]
thank you chairman takano and yes sir to
just answer uh congressman cawthorn
um
at least 12 years ago in the marine
corps before and after you deployed
there was pre-deployment training and
post-deployment training that's a
perfect time for the education to be
provided about what a toxic uh what a
burn pit is what airborne hazards are
have been known to be wherever they're
going um
whether it's a pamphlet a powerpoint or
just talking to navy corpsman doc
something should be
in that pre-deployment and
post-deployment training
well mr champion and lindsey if you
don't mind me asking one quick follow-up
question
forgive my ignorance for i've never
served before but
are
are people that are being deployed do
their commanding officers of the
department of defense do they normally
know that there's a burn pit active are
these these airborne pathogens are in
the area at before the deployment
happens
so
i can explain to you what i remember
from 12 years ago in my anecdotal uh
story but
i was the junior corporal in my shop so
uh when you're the junior guy in your
shop sometimes you volunteer sometimes
you get ball and told
i i would get volunteered to take out
the trash occasionally once a week and
sometimes you'd see a trash pit a trash
bin a recycling bin and then a burn bin
and the burn bin would be full of
what i remember the most were envelopes
because you don't want your parents
addresses your friend's addresses you
don't want to just get thrown away in a
combat zone you want to burn that so
that it's operation security to protect
that information
um so once or twice a week
i would empty that burn burn box take it
to the junior private in the squadron
and then that poor kid would have to go
walk to the burn pit and breathe in
i'm sure he went every three days um
whenever the
burn box would fill
um
but that's what i remember from
uh the air wing in the marine corps on a
c-130 squadron 12 years ago
i'd also like to
make a point there on that too is that
you're asking if commanders know about
this well the tod overall knew about
this because the contractors who start
the burn pits wherever we're at
make the dod sign a
letter stating that the dod can never go
back and pursue suit against the
contractor for the burn pits because
here's the list of the known effects and
toxic
exposures that are going to come from
these burn pits that can further cause
health impacts down the road and so the
dod is the one signing these contracts
you know to the contractors to protect
the contractors because they know how
bad these are
thank you mr thank you for that mrs
burns mr marowski
thanks mr chairman um a couple of quick
things one i wanted to respond to
congressman cawthorne because i think he
had asked for my input on his question
as well and i agree with what's already
been said is that it can't be too early
to start telling people about these
issues but you know
no matter how good especially when we're
talking about the transition assistance
program no matter how good it gets it's
always going to be
drinking from a fire hose and too much
information for the person at the time
so you have to tell them then you have
to continue to tell them afterwards too
you know these are conversations that
every you know va doctor should be
having with uh with a veteran every time
you know the primary care doctor should
be having it with him and bringing up
these things and so there are aspects of
the bill that would address that as well
so it's
never too early but it's it's during and
it's after as well um and then with um
what shane was talking about with the
backlogs that this could potentially
create hey
we don't like the va to have backlogs
but some we don't like backlogs when
there's no reason some backlogs uh are
good backlogs and those are backlogs
that are occurring simply because we're
getting the right veterans into the
system um and so uh you know if there
was a temporary backlog to be created by
uh the pac-tac that in and of itself is
not necessarily a concern with us uh you
know we consider that uh
you know part of the course
uh i want to go back thank you thank you
mr morrowski mr stewart i'm going to
give you the last word so uh uh i'll
give you last word i gotta i've got to
bring this to a close let me just say
that there is such a thing as
uh the benefit delivery at discharge
program
which i did see in action in korea on
the last codel i led during thanksgiving
break
that does make a really great great
attempt
to
deliver benefits upon discharge
give the veteran a physical
note any ailments at the time
but please understand that mr catherine
that this does not conclude
the subject matter of today i mean even
if uh
you know it includes
all of the benefits that relate to a bad
knee a hip uh something that an ailment
they're still
in the service and obviously
it's very much easier to determine
service connection when you kind of know
what's happening in that moment
but benefit delivery of discharge bdd is
the program is called is not universally
available it's available at some bases
in some places but it's not available
everywhere and even if we're available
everywhere it does not solve this issue
of all of our veterans that were exposed
to burn pits uh
in the post-911 era and in the
desert storm era et cetera et cetera mr
stewart i'm going to give you the last
word you've been so patient and
i commend you for sticking it through to
the very end not even our members of
congress do that
i shouldn't even say not even it's not
surprise but it's very surprising to see
someone uh who's obviously is
incredibly i'm incredibly busy and
popular and the fact that i've been able
to do this is a real testament
that's my uh to my stamina
uh i i wanted to sort of talk about it
on on kind of the bigger scale when we
talk about technology and we talk about
capacity and we talk about resources and
all the different things that we've sort
of been uh
knocking around here today because they
all come back to one
sort of fundamental truth
and that's priority
priority and intention
you know we keep hearing from uh members
of congress and people at the va and dod
this idea of capacity and the sort of
surprise that they all
express about the amount of people that
may be coming forward we've been at war
for 20 years
dod is the one who's making the va's
customers
this can all be seen coming from 100
miles away
dod and va both knew their internal
documents show in 2008 through 2010 the
toxic exposure was a deadly hazard for
american troops
va knew what was coming down so the idea
that all of a sudden there's this
capacity surge that no one understood or
saw coming it it's as though they were
filling up a bathtub
for years and then suddenly went what's
all this water on the floor
you know we we've been at war for 20
years there's 3.5 million veterans we've
had these giant burn pits
we all knew that this was coming so the
idea that we haven't been building
capacity up to this point
is really negligent
on on everybody's part
and i think the message uh that dod has
an enormous part to play in this is also
true it's very easy to go after the va
when dod is the one where there is
almost no oversight over the massive
resources that they get
and those resources have to also be used
to funnel into
va to help them take care of the
soldiers and not
hurt force readiness but part of
national security and force readiness is
the trust that you build up with the
veteran community that you will live up
to the obligations that they so clearly
have lived up to
and the final point is technology
and this is the one that's almost the
most unforgivable i mean for god's sakes
you've got darpa on the pentagon they've
got robot dogs out there trying to
figure out how to diffuse minds and yet
dod's computer system can't talk to the
va system and some of these remote va
offices are guys working on typewriters
and and it sounds like a joke but it
what it reflects is simply this
priority
the men and women who serve are the
greatest asset of the united states
military
and yet they are the lowest on the totem
pole when it comes to resources
we always have money for the technology
we always have money for the defense
contractors we always have sovereign
immunity for the defense contractors
and we always balance the budget on the
backs of those who come home
and try and uh reintegrate and that's
the the change in culture that has to
take place
and i know i'm talking to the converter
because i'm talking to the bsos and all
the representatives are gone but damn
man
it's crazy that we're even having this
meeting
and and very thankful that it's getting
done but this thing has to get done and
it has to get done with common sense and
with intentionality
so thank you very much for for having
this
and uh it is much appreciated
well thank you mr stewart
i very much appreciated you're pointing
out
the contradictions the stark
contradictions the
the robot dog
comment really hit home uh and i just
also point out
just to echo some of what dr ruiz said
earlier
uh i mean
it also echoes i think uh what
ms keenan said about
uh that the contractors actually got
signed documents from dod who said they
wouldn't be all liable well the fact is
dod itself
is not liable because dod does not fall
under
uh the same regulations that other
businesses in the united states fall
under all the other governments fall
under under osha
you know osha standards or local
environmental standards would have never
allowed these burn pits uh to have
existed
uh it's common sense to know that a burn
pit uh
of the size that you mentioned earlier
mr stewart simply would not be tolerated
in any community in the bounds of the
united states of america it just would
not
but dod you could do it because dod is
not bound
by
osha regulations for example dod is an
entity unto itself
so i want to thank
each of you for your attendance at
today's roundtable discussion on the
honor and impact act
uh when our country goes to war we don't
hesitate to pay for the armor
guns and tanks that our service members
need as mr stewart said it's a matter of
priorities
uh that we set
but
you know
armor guns and tanks aren't the only
cost of war we must ensure that we keep
our promise
to
toxic exposed veterans
veterans have already sacrificed so much
they shouldn't have to fight va or
congress for the benefits they have
earned and deserve no more
can congress cry for fiscal restraint
when it comes to paying for the care and
benefits of our veterans
it's really time we honor our pact
and prioritize veterans
and pay
the true cost of war
um i know that the ranking member has
had
to go or not i would ask him to make any
comments
um but i do want to thank him
and all the republican members and staff
for participating in today's
uh
uh
meeting and today's roundtable
is my hope that
that we will come together and speak
with a unified voice
make veterans our priority
uh it is a matter of priorities
and with that i'm going to call
these proceedings to close and thank you
all for your participation once again so
thank you
c-span's washington journal every day we
take